well one thing that I really do is I'm
really inspired by one of my mentors dr.
Robert Bullard who's considered the
father of environmental justice and one
thing that he says often is if you live
on this earth if you breathe this air
then you're an environmentalist and so I
come from that tactic in that that
school of thought where everything that
you do has is connected to the
environment in some capacity so one of
the trainings that I like to do the most
is that i will ask people what they're
interested in already and then give them
case studies directly connected to what
they're interested in and show how
environmental justice impacts that
specific situation and most the time
unfortunately i can use real life
situations so for instance it might say
like what does we you know you might be
interested in gentrification that's your
issue that you're important in so i'm
going to give you a case study directly
connecting gentrification to
environmental justice and urban sprawl
and acts access to resources like
transportation and jobs because those
are environmental justice issues the
ability to get from point A to point B
in your environment that's an
environmental justice issue or where
you're placing people when you deal with
gentrification oftentimes people go from
one environmental justice hazard in a
city to another environmental justice
hazard where it's a suburban area that
was built for new homeowners or
low-income residents and it's built on
top of a landfill or on top of another
environmental hazard so that happens a
lot and we just try and connect it
directly to what they're interested in
it doesn't even have to be a cause it
can just be like you like riding around
in your car bumping your music so let me
connect this to the environment and when
we do that that training I really like
doing it because even the people who
would not be engaged are engaged when
you when you do that train